WE'LL LET YOU DECIDE.
ADAM COROLLA WILL BE HERE TO
REACT AND THAT AND MUCH MORE
STRAIGHT AHEAD.
ALSO DEVELOPING TONIGHT FROM
UKRAINE HAS REPORTEDLY
RECAPTURED TWO KEY TOWNS.
WE HAVE THE LATEST ON THE
GROUND.
FIRST, THE EVER STRUGGLING
JOE BIDEN IS DOUBLING DOWN ON
REGIME CHANGE, RUSSIA PUTTING
THE WHITE HOUSE IN AS MUCH
DISARRAY AS EVER, SPINNING IN
CIRCLES ON EVERY SINGLE FRONT
AFTER YET ANOTHER ANOTHER BATCH
OF VERY BIZARRE BLUNDERS THAT
ARE SPARKING OUTRAGE FROM
AMERICAN ALLIES ALL ACROSS THE
GLOBE.
WE ARE NOW AT A POINT WHERE IT
IS PRETTY MUCH ANYONE'S GUESS
WHAT THE U.S. PRESIDENT ACTUALLY
NEEDS OR IS ACTUALLY SAYING AT
ANY GIVEN TIME.
BECAUSE JUST WHEN YOU THOUGHT TO
THOUGHT BIDEN COULDN'T GET ANY
WORSE, HE DID.
AND GOT ANYMORE OFF MESSAGE, HE
DID, ANYMORE DIVORCED FROM
REALITY, HE IS, FINDING NEW WAYS
TO STILL CONFUSION AND CHAOS
AFTER HIS OWN ADMINISTRATION HAD
TO CLEAN UP THREE HUGE SEPARATE
REMARKS OVER JUST A MATTER OF
DAYS ABOUT PUTIN'S BLOODY
INVASION AGAINST UKRAINE.
FIRST UP LAST THURSDAY BIDEN
ASKED ABOUT A POSSIBLE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS ATTACK BY RUSSIA,
TELLING REPORTERS THAT WOULD
TRIGGER A RESPONSE IN KIND.
WATCH THIS.
>> TO CLARIFY ON CHEMICAL
WEAPONS, WITH THAT TRIGGER A
MILITARY RESPONSE FROM NATO?
>> IT WOULD TRIGGER A RESPONSE
IN KIND.
>> Sean: A RESPONSE IN KIND,
MEANING WE'LL DO THE SAME THING.
JEFF SULLIVAN WAS FORCED TO
CLARIFY BIDEN'S REMARKS, SAYING
IT MEANT THAT THE U.S. RESPONDED
ACCORDINGLY.
WHY DIDN'T JOE JUST SAY THAT?
BIDEN CONTINUED TO SUGGEST THAT
THE U.S. TROOPS WERE HEADING
INTO UKRAINE.
LISTEN TO HIS OWN WORDS.
>> THE AVERAGE CITIZEN STEPPING
UP.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE IT WHEN YOU
ARE THERE, AND HOW LONG YOU'VE
BEEN THERE, YOU ARE GOING TO
SEAT WOMEN, YOUNG PEOPLE,
STANDING IN THE MIDDLE OF A DANG
TANK SAYING IT, I'M NOT LEAVING,
I'M HOLDING MY GROUND.
>> Sean: YOU WILL SEE WHEN YOU
ARE THERE?
THE WHITE HOUSE COLUMNS CAME TO
CLEAN UP THOSE REMARKS.
"THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CLEAR,
WE ARE NOT SENDING U.S. TROOPS
TO UKRAINE AND THERE IS NO
CHANGE IN THAT POSITION.
YOU WILL SEE IT WHEN YOU ARE
THERE.
THAT'S NOT ALL BECAUSE ON
SATURDAY, BIDEN WENT OFF SCRIPT
DURING A SPEECH THIS TIME IN
POLAND AND CALLED FOR, AGAIN,
REGIME CHANGE THAT THEY HAD
ALREADY CLEANED UP AGAINST
PUTIN.
WATCH.
>> UKRAINE WILL NEVER BE EVICTED
FROM RUSSIA.
THREE PEOPLE REFUSE TO LIVE IN A
WORLD OF HOPELESSNESS AND
DARKNESS.
WE'LL HAVE A DIFFERENT FUTURE, A
BRIGHTER FUTURE.
HOPE, LIES, DECENCY, DIGNITY,
FREEDOM OF POSSIBILITIES.
FOR GOD'S SAKE, THIS MAN CANNOT
REMAIN IN POWER.
>> Sean: MAKE UP YOUR MIND,
JOEY.
THE MEDIA GOT GIDDY.
EVEN AT THAT TIME ATTEMPTING TO
COMPARE HIM TO RONALD REAGAN AND
HIS COMMENTS, MR. GORBACHEV,
TEAR DOWN THIS WALL.
ANYWAY, SAYING IT WAS SIMILAR,
BIDEN SUGGESTING THAT NOW HE'S
FINALLY A STRONG LEADER.
IT WAS ALMOST IMMEDIATELY IN
DAMAGE CONTROL MODE AGAIN.
EVEN BIDEN'S OWN SECRETARY OF
STATE, THE WEEKEND TONY BLINKEN,
DIRECTLY CONTRADICTED PUTIN
SAYING THAT REGIME CHANGE IS NOT
ON THE TABLE YET AGAIN AND THE
WHITE HOUSE SAID IN ANOTHER
STATEMENT THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
POINT IS THAT PUTIN CANNOT BE
ALLOWED TO EXERCISE POWER OVER
HIS NEIGHBORS OR THE REGION.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HE SAID.
NOT PUSHING FOR REGIME CHANGE
PAID BY AGAIN TODAY HE SEEMED TO
MESSAGE REGIME CHANGE BUT NEVER
STOPPED!
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE BELIEVE WHAT HE'S DOWN
LIKE YOU SAID, PUT IN SHOULD NOT
REMAIN IN POWER.
DO YOUR WORDS COMPLICATE
MATTERS?
>> YOU ASKED THREE DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS AND I WILL ANSWER THEM
ALL.
NUMBER ONE, I'M NOT WALKING THEM
ANY BACK.
AS A MATTER OF IT IS I FELT MORE
OUTRAGE TOWARDS THE WAY PUTIN
HAS BEEN DOING AND THE ACTIONS
OF THIS MAN, JUST BRUTALITY.
>> Sean: NOT WALKING ANYTHING
BACK.
WE ARE BACK FOR REGIME CHANGE?
WE'VE ALL HEARD WHAT BIDEN
HIMSELF SAID.
IT'S HUMILIATING TO ME.
A PRESIDENT WHERE EVEN HIS OWN
STAFF HAS NO IDEA WHAT HE WILL
SAY OR WHAT WILL HE MEAN IF
ANYBODY WILL UNDERSTAND IT.
IT GETS EVEN WORSE.
JOEY DOESN'T THINK ANYONE WOULD
WALK BACK ANYTHING.
BY THE WAY, THIS WAS RIGHT AFTER
BIDEN DOUBLED DOWN ON REGIME
CHANGE MAY LOOK A LOOK AT THIS
WAS OUR EXCHANGE EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED THAT OTHER
LEADERS IN THE WORLD ARE GOING
TO START TO DOUBT THAT AMERICA
IS BACK, IF SOME OF THESE BIG
THINGS THAT YOU SAY ON THE WORLD
STAGE KEEP GETTING WALKED BACK?
>> PUTIN MADE US WALK IT BACK.
>> UNDER LIKE YOU TOLD U.S.
TROOPS THEY WERE GOING TO
UKRAINE AND IT WAS POSSIBLE THE
U.S. WOULD USE A CHEMICAL
WEAPON, AND IT SOUNDED LIKE YOU
WERE CALLING FOR REGIME CHANGE
IN RUSSIA, AND WE KNOW THE --
>> NONE OF THE THREE OCCURRED.
>> NONE OF THE THREE?
>> YOU INTERPRET THE LANGUAGE
THAT WAY.
I WAS TALKING TO THE TROOPS,
TALKING ABOUT HELPING TRAIN THE
TROOPS THAT ARE THE UKRAINIAN
TROOPS IN POLAND.
THAT'S IN THE CONTEXT.
I SAT THERE WITH THOSE GUYS WERE
A COUPLE OF HOURS.
THAT'S WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT.
>> Sean:
>> WHEN YOU SAID WE WILL SEE YOU
WHEN WE ARE THERE --
>> I WAS REFERRING TO BEING AND
TALKING WITH THE UKRAINIAN
TROOPS THAT ARE IN POLAND.
>> AND WHEN YOU SAID A CHEMICAL
WEAPONS USED BY RUSSIA WOULD
TRIGGER A RESPONSE IN KIND...
>> IT WILL TRIGGER A SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSE.
>> WILL THAT TRIGGER?
>> WHY WOULD I TELL YOU?
YOU'VE GOT TO BE SILLY.
>> THE WORLD WANTS TO KNOW.
>> WORLD WANTS TO KNOW A LOT OF
THINGS.
I'M NOT TELLING THEM WHAT THE
RESPONSE WILL BE.
RUSSIA KNOWS THE RESPONSE THE
RESPONSE.
>> Sean: AS WE PLAYED,
PETER DOOCY WAS COMPLETELY
RIGHT.
HE SAID ALL THREE.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT CLEARLY
IS NOT COGNITIVELY UP TO THIS
JOB.
THIS IS NOT AN OPINION.
THIS IS A FACT.
THE PRESIDENT DEPOSITOR'S
COGNITIVE DECLINE IS DANGEROUS.
THE LAW STREET JOURNAL
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL," ATWHS
VERBAL INCONTINENCE, WHEN DOES
IT START TO BECOME A MORTAL
THREAT TO AMERICANS?
QUITE ANOTHER TO CALL FOR THE
A-LISTER FOR THE AUTOCRATIC
LEADER WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
AND LEADERS AROUND THE WORLD,
THEY ARE NOTICING TOO ALLIES AND
ADVERSARIES.
FRENCH PRESIDENT, TELLING FRENCH
MEDIA THAT HE DID NOT APPROVE OF
THE WORD CHOICE AND OFFICIALS IN
GREAT BRITAIN MADE SIMILAR
COMMENTS AND BIDEN'S BLUNDERS
ARE ANOTHER GIFT TO BRUTAL THUG
DICTATOR OLIGARCH BLOOD IN HIS
HANDS VLADIMIR PUTIN AND THE
RUSSIANS AS THEY CONTINUE TO
KILL INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN WITH INDISCRIMINATE
BOMBING.
NO U.S. TROOPS ON THE GROUND.
NONE.
BUT IF YOU INVADE A SOVEREIGN
NATION LIKE PUTIN DATA AND
KILLING MEN, WOMEN, CHILDREN,
THE BLOOD IS ON THE HANDS OF
PUTIN.
YOU FORFEIT YOUR RIGHT TO LEAD
ANY COUNTRY.
FRANKLY, YOU WOULD FORFEIT YOUR
RIGHT TO EVEN LIVE.
HAD IT RIGHT FOR A SECOND BUT
ONLY 2 MINUTES AND THEY WALKED
AWAY.
SADLY WE NOW HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHOSE WORDS CAN NO LONGER BE
TRUSTED AND WHOSE AGENDA IS NO
LONGER CLEAR, COHERENT, AND THE
COPRINCIPAL.
DOES ANYBODY NO, DOES ANYBODY IN
THE WHITE HOUSE?
DOES JOE EVEN THOUGH TODAY IS
MONDAY?
IT'S ONLY GOING TO GET WEIRDER
AND MUCH CREEPY YEAR.
LOOK THIS MOMENT.
TALKING ABOUT THE WOMAN'S A
BEAUTIFUL LIES?
ENTIRE LIFE BEING UPENDED?
BACK COMES CREEPY JOE, TAKE A
LOOK.
YOUR FATHER OR YOUR MOTHER,
LET'S BE HONEST.
>> MY MAMA.
>> MOTHER'S EYES?
>> YOUR MAMA...
B1 JOE, WHY DIDN'T YOU STOP AT
"GOD LOVES YOU?"
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN PERFECT.
A YOUNG WOMAN, REFUGEE, ENTIRE
LIFE HAS BEEN UPENDED AND UP
POPS OLD CREEPY JOE.
I'LL ASK AGAIN TONIGHT.
COULD BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY GO ANY
WORSE THAN IT IS NOW?
INFLATION, FORTY-YEAR HIGH
THROUGH THE ROOF.
RECORD HIGH AFTER A RECORD HIGH.
NATIONWIDE FOOD SHORTAGE
LOOMING.
THE BORDER A CATASTROPHE.
THE AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL A
DEADLY DEBACLE.
AND NOW WE HAVE WAR IN EUROPE,
AND BIDEN, HIS OWN WHITE HOUSE
CAN'T KEEP THE STORY STRAIGHT.
CHINA THREATENING TO INVADE
TAIWAN.
I EXPECT THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IRAN HAS NEVER BEEN CLOSER TO
GETTING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
YOU'VE GOT JOE BIDEN SUCKING UP
TO THE MULLAHS OF IRAN IN A DEAL
THAT WOULD MAKE HIM RICH AS HELL
AND ALLOWED VLADIMIR PUT INTO
BROKER THE DEAL, YOU'VE GOT THE
DICTATOR OF VENEZUELA LITERALLY
KISSING THE ASS, BEGGING OPEC
NATION GETTING TURNED DOWN TO
PRODUCE MORE OIL, ALL WHILE
BIDEN CONTINUE TO ATTACK THE OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRY RIGHT HERE AT
HOME?
WE HAVE MORE NATURAL RESOURCES
THAN WE COULD EVER USE AND 200
YEARS.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
SINCE JOEY ENTERED OFFICE, BIDEN
HAS TAKEN 81 ANTI-ENERGY
ACTIONS.
HE KILLED THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE.
BY THE WAY, THE PREMIER IN
ALBERTA SAID IF WE FINISHED IT,
WE'D BE GETTING 900,000 BARRELS
OF OIL A DAY FROM CANADA.
HE IS IMPLEMENTING BURDENSOME
EMISSIONS REGULATIONS, CUTTING
OFF DRILLING AND AUCTIONING ON
FEDERAL LANDS AND A WHOLE HOST
OF OTHER FAR LEFT CLIMATE
ALARMIST RELIGIOUS CULT
POLICIES.
THE NEW GREEN DEAL SOCIALISM